thibault les vrais problèmes au départ
sur l'emploi de ce gros séparatisme que
je récuse absolument et que finalement
ne vais pas dire grand chose sinon qu'on
sait très bien que c'est racisme je peux
le comprendre pour les catalans ou pour
les corses mais je ne comprends pas du
tout ce que ça veut dire par rapport aux
musulmans et à l'islam en particulier
mais ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut bien
retenir c'est que tout ça c'est ça ne
vient pas de nulle part
et surtout il ya quand même déjà depuis
une vingtaine d'années un courant qui
effectivement parle d'un envahissement
distincts mais c'est d'abord pas revenir
là-dessus mais que les attentats ont
changé le logiciel d en changer de
logiciel
parce que l'effet de ciment on a
accrédité l'idée que effectivement ces
attentats de 2015 c'était une amende la
radicalisation mais que c'était une
islamisation de la radicalisation de
l'islam en général dans le monde et je
pense que le président de la république
est très influencé par ce point de vue
disons le quai le point de vue de deux
universitaires gilles kepel et de talent
de ces deux de ses protégés bernard
augier qui effectivement pour lesquels
il faut démontrer que s'il voulait c'est
l'islam qui pose problème à l'avenir
alors bien sûr c'est ces universitaires
dans leur ouvrage ne dise pas que les
musulmans seront à reprocher on peut
leur reprocher des choses mais on a
changé quand même le point de vue parce
que le point de vue jusqu'à 2015
c'était calais les bons musulmans à
l'école cela il faut les protéger
et puis avec les terroristes et les
mauvais musulmans et il y avait deux
poids deux mesures chaque fois que le
pouvoir politique prenne une décision
par rapport à cette situation
il y avait toujours je m'excuse 1 le
terme la carotte et le bâton
c'est à dire que l'on disait d'un côté
on va faire la loi sur le niqab et d'un
autre on va instituer la recension des
actes anti-musulmans là ont déjà ça
avait commencé avec manuel valls en 2012
mais là vraiment on est on n'a plus du
tout de cadeaux à faire voilà les
musulmans voilà vous êtes là vous êtes
confrontés à une radicale votre religion
maintenant prouvez nous que vous n'êtes
pas radicaliser que effectivement vous
faites le nécessaire pour éviter cette
vague
il
[Musique]